En este video vamos a hablar de las potencias
de 0; y sólo como un pequeño recordatorio,
empecemos con un número distinto de 0 para
recordar de qué trata todo eso de los exponentes.
Si trabajamos con 2 elevado a la primera potencia
(2¹), una forma de pensar en esto es que siempre
empezamos con 1 y después lo multiplicamos por
esta base tantas veces como indique la potencia,
así que aquí sólo tendremos un 2, nos quedará
1 • 2, lo cual es simplemente 2. Si pensamos
en cuánto es 2², esto será lo mismo que
1 por dos veces 2, entonces: 1 • 2 • 2,
que es lo mismo que 4. Y podría seguir así.
Ahora, la razón del por qué tenemos este 1 aquí
-y lo hemos visto antes- es para justificar, entre
muchas otras buenas razones, que 2 elevado a la
potencia cero (2⁰) debe de ser igual a 1, ya que
si usamos exactamente la misma idea, empezaremos
con 1 y lo multiplicaremos 0 veces por 2, así que
terminaremos sólo con 1. Les había dicho que este
video trataría sobre las potencias de 0, pero
hasta ahora sólo hemos estado haciendo potencias
de 2, así que concentrémonos en 0. Entonces, ¿a
qué crees que sea igual 0 elevado a la potencia
1 (0¹)? Pausa el video e intenta encontrar la
respuesta. Bueno, utilicemos la misma idea.
Empecemos con 1 y multipliquemos por 0 una vez: 1
• 0 = 0. ¿A qué crees que sea igual 0 elevado a la
segunda potencia (0²)? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bueno, será 1 por dos veces 0, entonces: 1 • 0 • 0,
y creo que puedes ver a dónde va esto. Esto
también será igual a 0. ¿A cuánto crees que sea
igual 0 elevado a cualquier número entero positivo
arbitrario? Bueno, será 1 por 0 tantas veces como
nos diga ese entero positivo, y esto una vez más
será igual a 0. Y, en general, puedes extender
esta misma idea: 0, elevado a cualquier valor
positivo, será igual a 0, así que esto es bastante
sencillo. Sin embargo, hay un caso interesante
por aquí. ¿Cuál crees que sea el resultado de 0
elevado a la potencia 0? Pausa el video y piensa
en la respuesta. Bien, esto en realidad está en
duda; diferentes personas te dirán resultados
distintos. Si usamos la intuición detrás de
la exponenciación que hemos estado usando en
este video, diremos "Muy bien, empezaremos con
1 y lo multiplicaremos 0 veces por 0", en otras
palabras, no tenemos que multiplicar este 1 por 0,
en cuyo caso sólo nos quedaremos con 1, 0⁰ = 1.
Otras personas dirán, "Oye, no, estamos trabajando
con el 0 y eso elevado a la potencia 0 tal vez
debe ser 0", y es por eso que muchas personas
lo dejan como indefinido. Entonces, la mayoría
de las veces verás que 0⁰ es o indefinido o 1.